13 real life years have passed between
the release of Avatar and its sequel the
way of water for the characters the Gap
was a little longer around 14 years what
have they been up to in that time
by the end of Avatar Jake Sully had
joined the navi cause and transferred
his Consciousness to a navi body he and
his beloved natiri have managed to
overcome their differences and agree to
start a life together
I see you
I see you
they're still together roughly 14 years
later and they've had a few kids there's
their oldest son netiam middle child
moak and youngest took Nerium and gloac
are teenagers who are relatively close
in age they're grown up enough that Jake
trusts them to go on missions with him
against the sky people tuck is a bit
younger at about eight years of age
during the main events of the film Jake
and iteri also have an adopted daughter
Kiri played by Sigourney Weaver Weaver
appeared in the first film as Dr Grace
Augustine who died in the conflict
between the navi and the humans
Augustine's Avatar body which was
rendered brain dead was pregnant with
Kiri at the time she's about 14 years
old in the way of water so her birth
most likely occurred shortly after the
events of Avatar the way of water
dedicates a ton of screen time to these
four children and it's clear future
sequels are going to develop them even
more
at a wave Water Press event Sam
Worthington revealed that director James
Cameron gave him a script for a project
that's become known as Avatar 1.5 to
help him prepare to play Jake again it
was Cameron's original plan for a sequel
to Avatar Worthington explained part of
that story was about them being Warriors
and taking on the battles of other clans
and things like that as we see in the
way of water human military forces have
only returned Pandora within the last
year so in the meantime Jake and nitiri
have kept busy with Pandora business
with their tribe battling other factions
on the planet getting themselves ready
for the return of the sky people what's
our plan maybe one day we'll actually
see Avatar 1.5 come to fruition on the
big screen Star Wars constantly jumps
around in its timeline after all
it may have taken more than a decade for
the military to return to Pandora but
they came back with some new tricks up
their sleeves the most prominent of
these is that Colonel courage and some
of his compatriots have returned as
avatars even though they were killed in
the first avatar their memories have
been uploaded to the new bodies they
even came up with a catchy name for the
project which you can see on the
Avatar's vests project Phoenix the
Phoenix of course is the mythological
bird who constantly dies and returns to
life theoretically what's stopping the
military from continuing to upload
memories into new bodies practically
making their top operatives Immortal by
the time porridge and his team arrive on
Pandora the military already has a full
base setup and operational they get
introduced to the new way of things this
time around and it's clear their Navi
bodies will be valuable Assets in the
Hostile landscape
of course there's more to be gleaned
between the events of Avatar and the way
of water than what's in the movies
themselves fans of comic books may know
there are various Avatar story lines
published by dark force Comics one of
which is the six issue series to tape
path in the first film sutaya Zindagi
Warrior who is initially betrothed to
nitiri and wary of trusting an outsider
like Jake however he finds himself
mortally wounded during the events of
the film anyone who wanted to believe
that sutei was more than just someone
competing for nitiri's braid and Avatar
should absolutely check out his comic
book series the event of the comics all
take place during Avatar but they help
fill in the gaps to make sutei a more
well-rounded character up until his
untimely demise at the hands of the sky
people
said shortly after the events of Avatar
the four issue dark force comic series
the next shadow sees the navi attempt to
pick up the pieces after most of the
human forces leave Pandora the aliens
went back to the Dying World Jake
meanwhile comes to terms with his new
life to really drive this point home the
series starts with Jake going to visit
the grave of his human body it isn't
long before some of the natural Navi are
skeptical of Jake's ability to lead and
some even plot to kill him by
challenging him to combat with a
poison-laced knife Jake catches the
knife allowing the poison to enter his
system while he searches for an antidote
he begins having visions of his previous
life including all of the deaths that
occurred due to his inaction it's more
of a spiritual journey for Jake than
anything else and he obviously gets the
antidote given that he appears in the
way of water
if you want to be fully caught up with
the story of Avatar before the way of
water dark Forces The High Ground which
is based on a script written by Cameron
is a must read it's set just before the
events of the way of water Jake nigeri
and their family have lived in relative
peace for years but Jake has always been
suspicious that the sky people could
return and that's precisely what happens
humans bring in Armada of shifts to
occupy Pandora once again Jake and a
teary round up as many Navi as possible
were willing to fight to protect their
home the story helps fill in the blanks
at the beginning of the way of water
even though we see the humans return to
Pandora in the movie it skips past how
their presence impacted the navi the
comic offers a better sense of the
sacrifices the navi made to protect
their home from the colonizers with the
comic Die Hard Avatar fans can get a
clearer picture of what transpired in
the Sci-Fi franchise so you can be ready
for the wave water and anything else
James Cameron has up his sleeves in the
planned sequels
[Music]